لقد جاؤوا إلى هنا على أمل الهروب من الحرب،
وهذا ما حدث
بعد ظهر يوم الثلاثاء، حيث قامت غارة جوية إسرائيلية على ما يبدو
بهدم هذا المبنى في وسط
غزة
تحت الرمال والأنقاض عبارة عن
جسد هامد هناك رأسه
يقول أحدهم إنه بدون معدات ثقيلة يجب أن تكون الأيدي العارية
كافية عند  المستشفى الوحيد الذي يعمل، تم
نقل المصابين إلى داخل
المستشفى، ويقول المتحدث باسم المستشفى إنهم
استقبلوا أكثر من 130 جريحًا وأكثر
من 90 جثة، ولا تستطيع سي إن إن تأكيد الوفاة
مرة أخرى، لذا فإن العديد من الضحايا هم
أطفال مذهولون ومرتبكون ومذعورون، وهي تمسك
بيد والدتها المصابة التي يعالجها
الأرضية الأكثر حظًا بين أولئك الذين فروا
ثم فروا مرة أخرى إلى الجنوب ينتهي بهم الأمر
في أماكن مثل هذه المخيمات المؤقتة
الخالية من المياه الجارية والكهرباء أو
الصرف الصحي، فالغطاء البلاستيكي هو كل ما
يحمي أنيس مصلح وعائلتها من
عناصر [الموسيقى] الموجودة بالفعل في غزة  الآن أصبح الخط الفاصل
بين الحياة والموت رفيعًا بشكل خطير،
والتهديد لا يأتي
من الحرب فقط. ويشعر مسؤولو الأمم المتحدة بالقلق من أن جميع
أولئك الذين أصبحوا بلا مأوى ويعيشون الآن في
ظروف غير صحية مع
إمدادات متضائلة من الغذاء والدواء يمكن أن
يقعوا قريبًا ضحية لذئب المرض.